hello and welcome to zero playing decks
on bra so let's see what's happening
here in this game what can I do I can
play the bank oh maybe let's go for the
bank oh um yeah let's go for the modern
way of handling this it's cancelled
smart before quiver IDK just he doesn't
play you for now interesting yeah well I
think here there are a couple of
additional options one is this I don't
have to take with the bishop necessarily
I'm not sure that this is actually
better I'm just saying it's a it's an
additional idea my D has to go night you
form if possible night before also might
be an irritating move of course you can
just go nite h4 but then I'll drop back
to the seven and try to argue that the
bishop is not that bad on d so maybe it
is and he has spent some time okay so
here like night before there is just a
three and yeah so what is that what can
I do here maybe I can play here Knight
to e5 Knight to c4 something like that
now let's let's see yeah what can I have
some useful things here oh that's
strange move night before looks like
it's it's helping me okay now i can take
on a to actually night a two-night takes
and then see form to regain it maybe
that's something better you know it
looks very strange the Queen down but i
think i'm happy that i'm getting this
back so my night though well I wonder
ever have a square for my night in this
operation the other hand on the other
hand if night a tool i also have bishop
to a four
okay okay okay then let's let's not be
too hectic here see for Queen somewhere
it actually should go maybe to III and
this F forum where my my night has no
squares it's really a funny thing the
reason why I'm also hesitating is that
Bishop f4 is not an utterly stupid move
maybe could could really be a move that
it's worth considering so C for 23 okay
to f4 and the damn night has got no
squares remarkable I have Bishop h6 in
this position but the night is still hmm
kind of kind of in a tricky spot is
there something that I can do
making g5 heard that's a totally wacky
move anyway I probably have to do it ok
this is I think not so problematic
because i have bishop a four I have
bishop a for now always and then the
night can drop back to the seven
mm yeah well maybe you can play I could
have inserted queen bee six year maybe
okay now well I have to check and be
should be three so I'm not losing my
rook very funny game there's a month so
i can check here check and then we
should be 3m
quince is 60 Mary
maybe I should actually play couldn't be
three not cannot Bishop b3 queen bee
three is probably stronger but should be
326 is kind of annoying taking the night
I cannot move it and I don't know if I
want to take it yeah maybe this I should
always have enough play against this be
to pawn here being a pawn down shouldn't
be a big issue
hmm it doesn't want to trade the Queen
that hmm I don't know where to where
we're able to go kind of surprised that
yeah it keeps it keeps the Queen's Own
hmm yeah that looks a little bit strange
to be honest but can be exploited I mean
the rookie has no squares for example so
Quincy to maybe which is not really
threatening anything we have to be
honest there can still move the bishop
for example but okay does he have a
threat here Queenie seven maybe just and
through time varnak f3 or then quince it
to against I'm covering this preparing
95 or 96 this will be a some some weird
time scramble anyway maybe just develops
the bishop well okay babe we should be
three half 9006
rogue f3 Quincy tool is getting injured
into time issues now okay I'm putting
this on the board where is he going now
yeah I think I'll just take this now
right it's grab stuff I think this
should be fine because my structure is a
little bit more healthy here that's a
probably a good move capacity for here
can I prevent this probably not again
that was a good move here's your phone
now which is very important now I think
the time will decide now I probably have
93 I had 93 years okay but the time
already so lay my offense yeah took too
long but it was a good game I think
buydig sandbar yeah I'm not sure about
all this here this is an interesting try
here with night to a sick sort taking on
a six um now here I don't know that it's
it's probably somewhat playable for
black I'm really not sure about the
objective merit I think this this is
probably all kind of normal and this is
probably not a good idea i would i would
assume yeah now here this is a very
debatable decision this is taking him
okay see form and now you went here I
think Queen III was a far more critical
move I'll take and now f4 I have to go
where g5 that was my idea but I couldn't
really figure out what what is what this
is yeah it's very strange if it takes
this I'm going to take here and ya mean
this is this is just total crew totally
crazy the engine thinks I'm I mean I'm a
lot better yet it's not something that I
could yeah then I would be a kind of
show about this is what i saw that i can
go g5 like here and then i have this
square here here very strange position
okay you went to see two ticks and now I
have this have this yeah probably i'm i
can i can play a 5 here okay now I
didn't see that one f5 tween here and
then the circuit computer very good
computer line just winning the exchange
okay no f5 I didn't consider I should
consider this move at least I mean it's
one thing not to play it but I should
consider it okay well this is not bad
yeah as I was seeing this and now okay
the engine prefers Bishop b3 yeah well I
wasn't too sure what to do here okay
Queen 870 strong didn't see Queen 87
yeah I know is now a screen is actually
offside ok ok ok Queen a7 is a strong
move ok
yay i still have a nice position okay
the engine wants to do this is it
stronger
okay it cannot be taken oh sorry not
this one course rookie 826 Quincy to
okay the rookie aid covers this again
and black is better so this was the was
an opportunity we should be three right
here I'm having good shape but it's
nothing spectacular Queen 82 is probably
a little bit better okay but here I was
reasonably sure that I will be known in
time so I didn't search too hard for the
best move yeah was a very good fight
here by by the white player I hope you
enjoyed the video thanks for watching